So I know there are a lot of steps in
that quiz and it was a lot to process.
So let's start off by looking
at the Android flavor app and
understanding that code
base first because it has
all these pieces working
together in a single project.
Remember, you can always download
a simple version of the project, import
app, and enter studio and it be easier
to navigate through all these files.
So if we scroll down to the bottom,
we see the ReadMe which is
the explanation of what this app is.
So this example uses a list view and
a custom array adapter called
Flavor Adapter to display a custom list
item view that contains that image and
two text views.
And so all this information is used to
display the Android flavor names and
version names.
So this item layout pattern and
custom adapter sound very similar
to what we need for the Miwok app.
So as a note, whenever the comments
in the app refer to the adapter view
it means a view such as the list view or
grid view.
Which are common adapter views.
So here we are again in Android Studio.
So I downloaded a zipped
version of the project and
opened it here in Android Studio
to explore it some more.
So to see how this project looks,
let's first explore the Java files.
So opening up, we see that there
are three Java files here.
And the first one to take
a look at is the MainActivity.
So given its name, it's probably
the main screen of the app.
So when we first open the app the main
activity is created by the onCreate
method and then we set the content
view to be activity_mainlayout.
So following that, we see there is
an array list call Android flavors that
contains objects of
the type Android flavor.
So Andrew flavor doesn't
sound like a standard class.
So it's most likely a custom class.
Now to check this out, we'll use
the declaration function in Android.
So to use this, iIll right
click on the name of the class,
go to Go To and then Declaration.
Nice so notice the jumps us
to the Android flavor class.
So the AndroidFlavor.java is
a custom class that we created.
Notice here that the objects of
this class have three properties,
version name version number,
and image resource ID.
So values for these are signed in
the constructor which we find down
here and this class also
contains some getter methods.
So what we've done is
we've created an array
containing these AndroidFlavor objects.
So here we have an example of
a single AndroidFlavor object.
So, with the knowledge of the box and
the states and sign, and
we've taken each of these objects and
put them inside an AndroidFlavors array.
So, many AndroidFlavor objects
are stored in an androidFlavors array.
So, let's go back to the MainActivity.
So, we just saw the array
list getting created up here.
So next are the array adapter calls.
So here's the line where we
instantiate a custom adapter that
is stored in a variable
called flavorAdapter.
Now to create this AndroidFlavorAdapter,
we call the constructor and
pass in two inputs.
So this one likely refers to the context
and the second one AndroidFlavors.
It sounds like we're passing in our
AndroidFlavors array so let's see more
of a host adapters to find by going to
where AndroidFlavorAdapters to find.
So right click, go to Declaration.
So here's
the AndroidFlavorAdapter Java file.
So notice at the top,
AndroidFlavorAdapter extends
ArrayAdapter, meaning that it
inherits from the ArrayAdapter.
So ArrayAdapter is a superclass and
AndroidFlavorAdapterr is a subclass.
So in addition to just inheriting from
ArrayAdapter, we also customize our
adapter class to expect the data source
to be a list of AndroidFlavor objects.
So let's take a look at its constructor.
Notice here that we called
the superclasses constructor, so
we're calling ArrayAdapters
constructor here.
And pass in three inputs.
Now if you remember back to
the discussion about inheritance,
because AndroidFlavorAdapter
extends ArrayAdapter.
We can use the constructor
from ArrayAdapter so
that we get all the logic to initialize
the state of the ArrayAdapter for
free without needing to
write that ourselves.
So this means we can take a look
into ArrayAdapter documentation
to find out more about its constructor.
So I'm back here in the ArrayAdapter
developer documentation.
I'm going to scroll down to
the public constructor section.
Now out of all of these public
constructors, the second to last one is
the one that we're using for
our AndroidFlavorAdapter.
So what we call the supercross
class constructor, AKA the array
adapters contractor,
we need to pass in three inputs.
So the context,
the list item layout resource ID, and
a list of AndroidFlavor objects.
So I want to copy this code and
paste it over here so
that we can have it to refer to
when we look back at our code.
Now we're back in Android
studio looking at the code for
the AndroidFlavorAdapter and
here's the constructor code for
the array adapter
the superclass in this case.
So notice here that we pass in
zero as the layout resource ID
because we don't need to rely on the
superclass array adapter inflating or
creating a list item view for us.
Instead, our Get view method will
mentally handle the inflating of
the layout from the layout
resource ID ourselves.
So moving down a little bit further,
we'll see more about
what I was talking about.
So, down here, we have the getView
method, and we're overriding the getView
method from the superclass and adding in
our own logic for a specific use case.
So, the comment above mentions that our
getView provides a list item view for
an AdapterView of some sorts.
An AdapterView like we mentioned
before could be either a ListView or
a GridView or
some other type of AdapterView.
So the getView method should
take in three parameters.
So the first is the position
which is the position in the list
of data this layout should represent,
the convert view
which is the RecycleView that needs to
be populated and the parent ViewGroup.
So the list items will be added to
this parent ViewGroup as children.
So the first step inside the GetView
method is the getItem method
which is originally defined in
the superclass ArrayAdapter.
So this method returns the item in
the list at the given index position and
note that the return value of this
method is an object with the datatype
AndroidFlavor.
And this is because in
the class declaration,
we specified an ArrayAdapter will
expect a list of AndroidFlavor objects.
So as a list a few calls
the getView method for
different positions in the list.
The adapter will go get the items
at the different positions,
in the list of androidFlavor objects.
So this androidFlavor object contains
the information though populate the list
item and
will read out that data from it shortly.
So the second input parameter of
the getView method is convertView,
which we said earlier is
an existing view that we can reuse.
However sometimes this view
will be equal to null.
Meaning that there is no
view that we can reuse.
So the view being null is common when
you first open up the activity, and
you're creating items in the list for
the first time to fill up the screen.
Now once the screen is filled up,
then it's likely that there will be
a valid view that we can we reuse.
Now in our case,
because we know that we're working with
list items, I'll assign convertView
to listItemView to make it clear what
type of view we're working with.
First, we check there's
an existing view that we can reuse
using this if statement.
If the list item view is dull,
then we execute this line of code inside
the if statement and this inflates all
new list item view from the XML
layout file called list item.
And in case you're wondering,
we're using a LayoutInflater which turns
the XML layout file into
actual view objects.
So we're manually inflating the view
which is why we don't need to pass
the layout resource ID to
the superclass in the constructor,
because remember here we passed in zero.
So once we know
the listItemView was valid and
not null, then we can start
update the text views and
image views within the list item
based on the AndroidFlavor object.
So notice that we're using the fine
view by ID calls to find the view within
the ID list_item_icon or
list_item_name or list_item_number.
So once we find ImageView and
TextViews, we can call methods like
setImageResource or setText and
pass in the value from the AndroidFlavor
object to change the data displaying
displayed on these views.
So to summarize,
from the current Android flavor object,
we can get the different states
from it such as the version name,
the version number,
and image resource ID.
So knowing that information from
the specific AndroidFlavor object,
we can set either the image of or
the text view,
to be the information that we've
gotten from the AndroidFlavor object.
So at the very end,
we return a list item view.
Which is the list item view
with updated information
from the current Android flavor object.
So this ListItemView will be added
as a child to the AdapterView.
All right so that's an overview
of how the AndroidFlavorAdapter
is a custom adapter the takes as its
input a list of AndroidFlavor objects.
So, when a list of items uses requested,
the AndroidFlavorAdapter will find the
Android view at the correct position and
then create or reuse a list item layout.
So the views will be updated based on
the information in the AndroidFlavor
object and then the list item view
is returned to the list view.
So back to the main activity.
So the last two lines are related
to implementing the list view and
array adapter.
So one that we've seen before
when modifying them you walk up.
So here we get to
reference the listView and
we're calling that reference listView.
And then finally we attach
the flavorAdapter to the listView so
we can populate it with data.
All right so we just unpacked
a rather complex structure.
So let's recap all of it.
So first off we created a way
to store custom objects.
And in this case we use
the androidFlavors array
which contains AndroidFlavor objects.
Next we create a custom adapter that
extends from the ArrayAdapter and
takes a custom object.
So in this case,
we created AndroidFlavorAdapter
which extends from the ArrayAdapter.
And it took in the custom
object AndroidFlavor.
Also for the last step,
we modified the getView method
in the custom adapter to provide
a list item view for your ListView.
So we modify the getView method
to get AndroidFlavor objects
from the ArrayAdapter.
So those at the appropriate position and
then to use that information to populate
either recycled View or
to populate a newly created View.
So I highly recommend you to walk
through this project on your own and
see if you can move through how
all these pieces fit together.
So it's well documented.
If you do ever get lost,
refer back to the walkthrough above.
If it helps,
draw out a diagram of the connections.
So understand that the custom
ArrayAdapter pattern is a very powerful
concept for displaying list in Android.